abracadabra youtubers is Charlie the BBC
just released the first official images
of Peter Capaldi's new Doctor Who outfit
and he's a magician no I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding but I didn't want to
talk about the top five things that are
really awesome about it as well as you
know the top five things that maybe
aren't quite so awesome just to make
sure you guys get a chance to voice your
reactions / LOL / rage i'm gonna be
doing a Doctor Who series 8 Q&A later
this week be sure to subscribe to get it
feel free to post any series 8 related
question you want you know anything
about the costume or the plots are or
anything else so let's start off on a
positive note here are the top 5 things
that I think are good about this new
costume number 5 it pays homage to Jon
Pertwee in the news release the BBC sent
out they didn't address this
specifically they just addressed the
absence of frills like ruffles and a
scarf I'm not sure why they added the no
scarf line but it definitely looks like
the Third Doctor's costume number 4 it's
age-appropriate Peter Capaldi is
actually one of the oldest people to
play the doctor so not wearing Sancho's
like Tennant is a plus they really
played up the old-time eNOS of all of
Matt Smith's costumes and yes it worked
because his doctor was so silly but
Capaldi's doctor is supposed to be much
sterner much more serious Allah the
heat-vision eyes he was giving off
during the 50th anniversary number 3 it
honors the eleventh Doctor's outfit one
of them anyway each new doctor gets to
pick his own first outfit although
Moffat does get a few vetoes it's really
cool the Capaldi chose to keep the
purple waistcoat aspect of Smith's
doctor as well as the black boots
they're similar but not the same Capaldi
is wearing Doc Martens and Matt Smith
wore 18-hole lace-ups
number two it's much more practical the
no frills and plainness of it make it
seem like we're headed for a much more
serious series 8 the costume and
personality of the doctor really do set
the tone and if he dresses and acts in a
much more Stern serious way doesn't that
mean that the stories are going to be
that much darker we could talk about
that more during the Q&A and my number
one good thing about the new costume
there is no neck wear with 13 different
actors to play the role counting John
Hurt it's almost impossible to wear any
article of clothing without it looking
like an homage to a previous doctor and
with exception to maybe the Fez and the
Cape things worn around the neck have
always been the most identifiable piece
of the doctors costumes so the easiest
way to differentiate yourself is to just
not wear anything
true Jon Pertwee also had a version of
his costume without neck wear but he did
have ruffles and thank God that ruffles
are not making a comeback so now let's
talk about the top five things that
maybe aren't so great about the costume
number five it doesn't have the warning
look of all the other doctors previous
outfits
yes Capaldi is a brand-new doctor but
his clothes are supposed to come from
the TARDIS's wardrobe so he typically
picks articles of clothing that he's
picked up over the course of the last
thousand years or so clean clothes are
nice but I feel like the doctor's outfit
should look like it's already got a lot
of city miles on it like a really used
car number for the reveal only came
because they were getting ready to film
outdoors it would have been nice to have
a big official reveal but the only
reason they really showed us his costume
was because images were getting ready to
leak I don't have a huge problem with
this but the news was more of a reaction
to that rather than a grand unveiling
number three not acknowledging the
similarities to the previous doctor's
costumes all the official news release
said was no frills no scarf clearly we
can see aspects of the third doctor's
costume why not officially acknowledge
it even if it is just a coincidence
Pertwee would have been one of Capaldi's
first doctors to watch he would have
been about twelve whenever the third
doctor's run started so it's possible
that some of that rubbed off on him when
it came time for him to pick his own
doctors outfit number two he's a
magician
the third doctor's outfit was
intentionally silly because that was
something of the style at the time
Capaldi might not be wearing a cape but
the red lining gives him this magician
look that has kept the people of tumblr
very busy as you can see and my number
one thing that's not quite so hot about
the costume there is no neck wear yes I
realized I said this earlier and yes
it's important to be different but I
can't help but feel that neck wear is
such a big part of Doctor Who that
eventually Capaldi will have to wear
some even if it's only as a momentary
reference or joke so now it's your turn
to let me know what is your reaction to
this new costume positive or negative
remember in that Q&A I'll be including
my favorite reactions from you guys
comments not just the funny ones though
so let me know what you think be sure to
subscribe to get that video I'll try to
post it by Friday right now click here
for my Doctor Who series 8 predictions
and click here for my Sherlock series 4
predictions thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you